تم إرساله جنوب جوهانسبرج ،
المسعف محمد رسول ، يقول إن أوميكرون
لا يشبه دلتا خلال ذلك الوقت ، لم يكن هناك
سوى مطمعا غولدوود يذهب
سرا ولا شيء آخر سوف تكون قادرًا
على المشي سيدي كنا معهم خلال
الفوضى عندما اندلعت موجة دلتا من الطمع 19
من خلال جنوب إفريقيا ،
تحطم المرضى الحادون بسرعة ،
أمضى فريق رسول ساعات في البحث عن أسرة المستشفيات ،
مثل هدية المانحين ، وهرعوا
إلى إنشاء عيادات ميدانية تتدافع
لتوزيع مكثفات الأكسجين لإنقاذ
الأرواح من خلال قولهم إنهم لم
يرسلوا واحدة ، إنها  يقول المريض
الذي يشكو من ضيق في
رسول الصدر إنهم ينادون الآن
لصبر أقل شدة
مثل هذا البالغ من العمر 46 عامًا والذي كان اختباره
سلبيًا ولكن لا يزال يشتبه في
أنه غطى مرض الساريا يقول بعد خمس
دقائق فحص الصدر
ولكن كانت هناك زيادة في حالات
السرقة  19 مع omicron ولكن لم
يكن هناك زيادة في الشدة أو
الاستشفاء ، فإن هذا النوع من الاستدعاء
نموذجي جدًا  dvice هل لديك
للبلدان الأخرى التي تواجه
موجة omicron لا داعي للذعر هذا أه
سوف تركب الموجة استخدام أقل
بكثير للأكسجين عدد أقل بكثير من الأشخاص الذين يتم
قبولهم على الرغم من الأعداد الكبيرة
للحالات انتقال مرتفع للغاية للأشخاص الذين يعانون من
اعتدال.  لا يتم تشخيص المرض حتى
في المنزل
، ولا يزال من غير الواضح سبب
كونه يبدو أكثر اعتدالًا أو ما إذا كان ذلك سيترجم
عالميًا
يعتقد العلماء هنا أن ما يصل إلى 80 في المائة
من السكان في جنوب إفريقيا ربما
يكونون قد عانوا من السرقة 19 قبل
أن يوفروا على الأرجح درعًا مناعيًا
ضد الإصابة بالعدوى الشديدة.
يلعب أيضًا دورًا رئيسيًا
كان من الممكن أن يكون كابوسًا مطلقًا
إذا كانت دلتا ، لذا أعتقد أنه
يمكننا أن نكون ممتنين للغاية لأنه
لم يكن مدمرًا كما كان يمكن أن يكون
ولكن لا يزال هناك سبب لتوخي الحذر
يبدو أنه حسنًا.  لقد تعلمت
مع النحاس عمومًا أنك لا تخذل
حذرك أبدًا للحظة وجيزة على الرغم من أن
رسول يجرؤ على الأمل في أن شدة
المرض ليست كذلك  لقد كان الأمر كذلك ، فأنا في
الواقع
متفائل جدًا حيال هذا الأمر
ديفيد ماكنزي سي إن جوهانسبرج